Voici une B.D. du Los Angeles Times. La chute ?
« D'un autre côté, je n'ai pas à me lever à 4 h pour traire mon Labrador. »
Voici une récente couverture du New York Magazine.
De si bons hôpitaux que les docteurs y iraient soigner leurs cancers,
accouchements, attaques, maladies du cœur, pose de hanches… ... Urgences à quatre heures du matin.
Un petit medley de mon crû :
(Chansons citant « Quatre heures du matin »)
« Quatre heures du matin » ne serait-il pas devenu une sorte de raccourci ou de code ?
Qui dirait : vous êtes debout à l'heure la pire de la journée.
(Rires)
Une heure qui perturbe, où l'on s'aventure, où l'on s'enflamme.
Parfaite pour comploter contre le chef de la police comme dans cette scène mythique du Parrain.
Le scénario les décrit « exténués, chemises ouvertes.
Il est quatre heures du matin. »
(Rires)
Une heure propice à plus louche encore, comme les autopsies et embaumements du roman d'Isabel Allende
« La Maison aux esprits. »
Après que la stupéfiante Rosa aux cheveux verts soit assassinée, les docteurs préservèrent son corps avec des onguents.
Ils travaillèrent jusqu'à quatre heures du matin.
Une heure propice à plus louche encore, comme dans le dernier numéro d'avril du New Yorker magazine,
où une nouvelle de Martin Amis commence par « Le 11 septembre 2001, il ouvrit les yeux
à 4 heures du matin à Portland dans le Maine, et ainsi commençai le dernier jour de Mohamed Atta. »
Pour une heure que je considère personnellement comme la plus plate et la plus insignifiante de la journée,
quatre heures de matin a plutôt mauvaise réputation. (Rires)
Lire de nombreux articles signés de nombreuses pointures m'a rendu soupçonneux.
Je me suis dit : comme si les esprits artistiques les plus créatifs de la planète
allaient tous se ramener à cette même métaphore facile comme s’ils l’avaient inventée !
Se pourrait-il qu'il y ait ici quelque chose de plus ?
Quelque chose de voulu, de secret, et qui donc a bien pu ouvrir le bal des « Quatre heures du matin » ?
Moi je dis, cet homme : Alberto Giacometti, photographié ici avec certaines de ses sculptures sur le billet de 100 francs suisses.
Il y est parvenu avec cette œuvre exposée au musée de New York.
Intitulée : « Le Palais à quatre heures du Matin. »
(Rires)
Et ce n'est pas seulement ma plus ancienne référence.
Je prétends que cette soi-disant première sculpture surréaliste
est en réalité l'improbable clé à potentiellement toutes les représentations artistiques futures de quatre heures du matin.
Ce que j'appellerais « Le Giacometti Code », une exclusivité TED.
Non, n'hésitez pas à suivre sur vos Blackberry, ou vos iPhones si vous les avez.
Voilà comment cela se présente : voici une récente recherche sur Google de « Quatre heures du matin ».
Multiples résultats, bien sûr. Classique.
Le Top 10 se compose de quatre résultats pour la chanson de Faron Young « Il est quatre heures de matin »,
trois pour le film de Judi Dench « Quatre heures du matin »
un seul pour le poème de Wislawa Szymborska « Quatre heures du matin ».
Mais, me direz-vous, quel point commun entre un poète polonais, une lady britannique et un chanteur de country music,
mis à part cet excellent référencement sur Google ?
Commençons par Faron Young — qui est né, cela dit en passant,
en 1932.
(Rires)
Il se suicida d'une balle dans la tête le 9 décembre 1996.
Qui est, soit dit en passant, l'anniversaire de Judi Dench.
(Rires)
Mais il ne mourra pas ce jour.
Il subsista jusqu'à l'après-midi suivante, où il périt finalement d'une blessure par balle qu'il se serait tirée lui-même, à l'âge de 64 ans —
qui est, soit dit en passant, l'âge d'Alberto Giacometti lorsqu'il décéda.
Où était alors Wislawa Szymborska ? Elle a l'alibi le plus parfait de l'histoire du crime.
Ce même jour, le 10 décembre 1996, pendant que Monsieur Quatre Heures du Matin, Faron Young, rendait l'âme à Nashville,
une Madame Quatre Heures du Matin, Wislawa Szymborska
se trouvait à Stockholm en Suède, où elle acceptait le prix Nobel de littérature
100 ans, au jour près, après la mort d'Alfred Nobel lui-même.
Coïncidence ? Non, c'est flippant.
(Rires)
Une coïncidence est bien plus simple.
Cela serait comme ça : « Tu savais que le prix Nobel a été créé en 1901,
qui est par coïncidence, l'année de naissance d'Alberto Giacometti ? »
Non, tout ne s'emboîte pas parfaitement dans le paradigme,
mais cela ne veut pas dire qu'il n'y a pas quelque chose de caché dans les plus hautes sphères.
En vérité, il y a des gens, dans cette salle, qui préféreraient que moi, je ne vous montre pas à vous, cet extrait.
(Rires)
Vidéo : Nous avons tennis, piscine, cinéma…
Vous voulez dire que si je veux des côtelettes de porc la nuit, votre gars les fera frire ?
Bien sûr, il est payé pour ça.
Vous faut-il des serviettes, du linge, une bonne ?
Attendez, attendez, attendez ! Alors si j'ai bien compris le jour de Noël, quatre heures du matin,
mon ventre gargouille.
Homer, s'il te plaît.
Attendez, attendez, attendez !
Alors si j'ai bien compris, Matt,
(Rires)
quand Homer Simpson a besoin d'imaginer le moment le plus improbable, pas seulement de la journée,
mais de tout le foutu calendrier, il choisit 4 heures du matin l'anniversaire du petit Jésus.
Et non, je ne sais pas comment cela s'emboîte dans l'inextricable puzzle des choses, mais de toute évidence,
je sais reconnaître un code secret quand j'en vois un.
(Rires)
Je dis : je sais reconnaître un code secret quand j'en vois un.
Mes amis, vous pouvez acheter « Ma vie » par Bill Clinton à la librairie ici,
le disséquer pour trouver Dieu sait quelles références,
ou trouver cet extrait sur le site web de l'éditeur.
Et jusqu'où nous faudra-t-il aller à votre avis, pour tomber sur le ticket gagnant ?
Le croirez-vous, au bout d'une dizaine de paragraphes ?
On y trouve p. 474, si vous me suivez :
« Pourtant meilleur qu'à l'origine, je n'étais toujours pas satisfait de mon discours inaugural.
Mes assistants devaient s'arracher les cheveux, car alors que nous étions encore debout à quatre heures du matin
le jour de l'investiture, je modifiais encore mon discours. »
C'est cela, oui ! Tu t'es préparé toute ta vie
à cet évènement historique qui déboule sans crier gare !
Et c'est alors
(Rires)
que trois paragraphes plus loin, je tombe sur ce petit bijou :
« Nous rentrions à la Maison, l'y lire une dernière fois.
Il était bien meilleur depuis quatre heures du matin. »
Ah bon, et comment est-ce possible ?
Selon lui, à cette heure,
soit il dormait, soit il priait avec Al et Tipper, soit il apprenait à lancer un missile nucléaire depuis une mallette.
Qu'arrive-t-il aux présidents américains à quatre du matin à l'investiture ?
Qu'est-il arrivé à William J. Clinton ?
On ne le saura peut-être jamais.
Et ce n'est pas comme s'il était ici, prêt à répondre à toutes ces questions.
(Rires)
Ça pourrait devenir embarrassant !
Tout cela s'est produit sous son nez !
Si seulement il pouvait être là...
(Rires)
Il pourrait nous rappeler, comme il le fait dans le résumé de son autobiographie, que ce jour, Bill Clinton commença un voyage.
Un voyage qui fit de lui le premier président démocrate élu
pour deux mandats consécutifs, depuis des générations.
Le premier depuis cet homme, Franklin Delano Roosevelt, qui commença son voyage sans précédent,
il y a bien longtemps, lors de sa première élection,
il y a bien longtemps, en un temps où tout était plus simple, en 1932.
(Rires)
L’année où Alberto Giacometti (Rires)
réalisa « Le Palais à Quatre Heures du Matin. »
L'année, ne l'oublions pas, où cette voix, qui nous a quittés,
vint au monde, ce monde géant et fou qui est le nôtre.
(Chanson citant « Quatre heures du matin »)
(Applaudissements)